recién nacidos bajo las bombas rusas el
sonido de las alarmas se mezcla con el
llanto de estos bebés que acaban de
llegar al peor de los mundos en el
sótano del hospital de maternidad en
kiev la sitiada capital de ucrania el
show women are given frost system he
visto a mujeres dando a luz aquí en el
sótano estaban todas ensangrentadas
porque por ejemplo les habían practicado
una cesárea y entonces la alarma empezó
a sonar y tuvieron que bajar así que
básicamente no tuvieron tiempo de
tumbarse después de la cesárea sant blai
out 6 section allí en condiciones
precarias
los doctores trabajan a contrarreloj
desde que inició la invasión del kremlin
intentando calmar los nervios de las
madres primerizas que agradecen que los
médicos no hayan huido de la ciudad
la mayoría de nuestro equipo no ha
salido del edificio desde el 24 de
febrero alrededor del 70% del personal
se queda aquí permanentemente nos
turnamos en el trabajo robot desde el
pasado jueves en el búnker de este
hospital de chernigov han nacido 46
niños en estas camas improvisadas las
madres lactantes duermen a sus bebés
del frío y de la ofensiva muchas están
solas puesto que sus maridos se han
enrolado como voluntarios para repeler
al ejército ruso sepla no tuve una
cirugía planificada ocurrió entre dos
ataques aéreos habría muerto si hubiera
estado en las trincheras no podía dar a
luz sin asistencia médica
todas comparten el mismo anhelo
quiero que mi hijo viva en un país
hermoso y luminoso siempre me ha
alegrado de estar en ucrania algunas
personas no están contentas con el nivel
de vida en mi país me gusta a todos no
quiero otro país william hague otras
desesperadas familias han optado por
salir de ucrania que ya superan el
millón de refugiados